[Music]
hey wisecrack jared IRL again for those
puffing in for the first time this is
still an experiment where we quickly
respond to developments in TV and film
as they happen not just Rick and Morty
so if you like them or have a request
let us know The Vindicator story return
of the world ender was a pretty awesome
job in Marvel movies with deep
indicators acting as an obvious stand-in
for the Avengers and Rick acting as a
mouthpiece for people disillusioned with
the rather formulaic state of popular
cinema the writers of their own press
releases Morty there are a bunch of
drama queens it's been an hour talking
at 20 minutes jumping around while [ __ ]
blows up there are fades we did one it
was the big event of that summer let it
die but instead of focusing on Rick's
beef with our Disney overlords we're
gonna set our sights a little higher
today superhero films have been clumsily
grasping with the concepts of good and
evil for what seems like an eternity and
this episode of Rick and Morty comments
on this and some pretty clever and even
profound ways welcome to this wisecrack
quick take on Vindicator 3 the return
overworld and you guessed it spoilers
ahead first a recap morty gets to choose
the next adventure with rick so he
decides to spend it with his heroes The
Vindicator
in good Sanchez II in fashion Rick gets
blackout drunk destroys the ominous
world ender with little effort and traps
of indicators in a series of trials that
ruins them the real our code of
indicators three like another morty
adventure Reno is Morty's optimistic
worldview crumbling around him in the
case of meeseeks and destroy' Morty's
wholesome view of fairy tales erodes as
the genre is subverted
in this episode Morty's faith in The
Vindicator Z roads as the superhero
genre is suburban but beneath all the
world Enders and superhero jokes so your
origin is what you fell into a vat of
redundancy this episode is also about
the complexities of good and evil
unlike some adventures where Morty's
view of the world is shattered
Rick plays a unique role in making his
worldview disintegrate here
after killing world ender while blackout
drunk Rick creates a saw inspired puzzle
that is less a thought-out plan to make
people confront their demons all la
jigsaw and more a drunken scheme to push
people over a moral cliff and it works
Vance shows his true colors you're the
learning-disabled photo-op win this is
triggering me I need space I need space
million ants kills Allan rails over a
woman and Crocky bot brings out the
Vindicator 'he's little secret nothing
we exterminated a planet by the end Rick
gets to lord over Morty about the sham
that is heroism
I appreciate it Morty I know you were
sucking the kool-aid out of the
Vindicator so the fact that I was right
about them must be pretty hard to admit
yeah it is what's really clever about
this episode is how they draw from some
of the more unique villains in popular
cinema Rick is this a saw thing are you
seriously sawing The Vindicator
Morty I'm a drunk not a hack unlike most
antagonists jigsaw isn't about senseless
murder or financial gain he wants to
change people's paradigms by making them
endure suffering in some cases to make
them appreciate life more similarly
drunk Rick's trials aren't meant
primarily to eradicate The Vindicator 's
but rather to create a moral crisis for
them proving to Morty that they are not
heroes
everyone in the universe is a hero mom
right we don't need jackets and I'm
pretty sure we don't need Vindicator
now I thought this was pretty cool in
itself but what I thought really
elevated this episode was a less obvious
inspiration the Joker
Morty's trip in the carnival ride seems
inspired by Alan Moore's The Killing
Joke when Commissioner Gordon is
tortured by the Joker like jigsaw the
Joker isn't only motivated by murder
he's out to prove that with one
sufficiently bad day Gordon could become
just as mad as him as another Joker
inspired by The Killing Joke puts it sea
madness as you know yes and what is
Ric's shenanigans in this episode but to
push the Vindicator x' to lose they're
just as the Joker infects the once
idealistic Harvey with his nihilistic
philosophy by killing Rachel and turning
corrupt cops against him so too does
Rick turned the benevolent indicators
into violent backstabbers
thus appending Morty's simplistic
understanding of good and evil you
manage to destroy just about everything
today the villains the heroes the lines
between them my childhood thank you okay
so Rick doesn't really buy that heroes
are good but there's a larger point
about how the way we're spoon-fed
narratives of good and evil is actually
super bad you know narratives like this
one everyone in the universe is a hero
all you have to do is know the
difference between good and bad and root
for good but thinking in such simple
terms can lead to problems for
philosopher Jacques Ron sea air
the problem with evil with a big capital
e you know the kind in every single
superhero movie is that any kind of
conflict becomes the ultimate struggle
of good and evil the value of winning
that battle becomes well Infinite it's a
fight for the soul of the world or
galaxy or universe all or nothing
so people can do even be worth in the
world to achieve victory but as the
logic goes isn't it justified what's so
bad about letting a few thousand people
die if it means destroying ultimate evil
well what happened on Dorian 5 nothing
nothing we exterminated our planet wait
huh do nama Tron was hiding there he's a
shapeshifter
destroying Dorian five was the only way
to kill him it could have made you a
device to detect doom namah Tron from
orbit like that what does this say about
the Vindicator z-- to summarize run C
air
the problem with infinite evil whether
in the form of world destroyers or
mortal humans is they warrant infinite
justice the kind that doesn't really
care about morals or the people of
Dorian v and often even loses sight of
the Justice part by the end of the
episode supernova has also been infected
with Ric's nihilistic philosophy no
longer believing in a real division
between good and evil
however she recognizes the simplistic
division must be upheld it's like you
said the morning if there's no right or
wrong it's the galaxy's faith in The
Vindicator z-- that keeps the galaxy
secure she's willing to kill Rick and
Morty and even her lover to protect the
perception that the Vindicator czar good
it's not their actions that matter it's
the galaxy's faith in their actions that
does I'm pretty sure this is another
shout-out to the Dark Knight which is
probably the best example of moral
grayness in a comic book movie where
Batman lies about the goodness of Harvey
Dent to maintain peace and order in
Gotham supernova wants the galaxy to
believe in a similar lie about herself
in both cases people are advocating for
a noble lie the idea that societies can
be built on a myth that maintains order
an idea made famous by the Greek
philosopher Plato and it's not the first
time Rick and Morty has made this kind
of Dark Knight as noble I shoutout we
found it inside a lockbox inside King
jellybeans closet we have to tell the
people wait
destroy it
[Music]
our people will give more from the idea
he represented than from the jellybeans
he actually was now this is kind of
philosophy 101 but it's worth noting at
least because of its relation to the
Dark Knight but where the Dark Knight
kind of celebrates the sly
Rick and Morty uses it to deconstruct
the myth of superheroes Rick says good
and bad or artificial constructs yeah
well I get the feeling it kind of needs
that to be the case however rather than
just deconstructing good and evil as
arbitrary concepts which by the way it's
done before I mean seriously I may be
the devil but your grandpa is the devil
the show is also suggesting that the
complete absence of these concepts isn't
so great either this is a clever
callback to the last episode where dr.
Wong confronts Rick in saying only
connection between your unquestionable
intelligence and the sickness destroying
your family is that everyone in your
family you included use intelligence to
justify sickness whereas The Vindicator
fail to critically engage with their
methods or even their mission
Rick refuses to engage with his
decisions for the exact opposite reason
because nothing matters and if nothing
matters and good and evil are just
social constructs then he can't consider
his actions evil he can just continue
doing whatever he wants so the episode
presents us with two differing
perspectives regarding good and evil
both of which are in typical Rick and
Morty fashion completely dismal we
either have zero conviction of the
division between good and evil which
leads Rick to doing whatever he wants
and it not mattering or we have complete
and utter conviction of what constitutes
good and evil and people end up doing
really messed up for the sake of good
like blow up an entire planet as always
in Rick and Morty there are no right
answers only wrong ones if you want to
hear more depressing Rick and Morty
philosophy check out our Rick and Morty
podcast the Squatch we're breaking down
every episode in detail answering your
questions and you'll even get to hear
the Joker impression I've been working
on for nearly a decade it's getting
there click on the link below or
subscribe wherever you get your podcasts
stay good wisecrack peace
[Music]
[Music]